sese dessine une autre crise
àà la a suite de la pandémie :
l'l'insécurité alimentaire,
ququi touche de plus en plus
d'd'étudiants.
" "En moyenne, 40 à 4 48 %
dedes étudiants du post-secondae
didisent êtrtre en insécurité
alalimentaire grave", dit-il,
"c"ce qui veut dire qu'ils sautt
auau moins un repas par jours".
SoSon organisme, Meal Exchange,
a a mené une étude sur plusieurs
cacampus à t travers le pays.
DeDe nombreux étudiants n'ont ps
pupu c compter sur leurs emplois
àà tememps partiels, pour subver
àà l leueurs besoins de base.
MAMARIE DOLCETTI-KOROS, trésorie
FéFédé. can. des étudiants
- - Beaucoup d'étudiants
trtravaillent dans le secteur
hohospitalier et donc ils ont eu
dede la difficulté à t trouver e
l'l'emploi l'été passé.
- - Il a aussi fallu payer des
frfrais de scolarités qui ont
auaugmenté.
- - Et nous avons aussi une crie
dede dette au Canada.
SaSanjana paie plus du double
paparce qu'elle est étudiante
ététrangèrere.
" "J'ai trouvé ça difficile
d'd'avoir accès àà dee
lala nourriture", raconte-t-ell,
"c"car je vis loin du campus ete
nene pouvais pas me payer de res
dedehors".
- - Le prix des aliments,
lului aussi a bondi.
" "Nous estimons que le prix ds
dedenrées alimentaires a bondi
d'd'environ 5 % en raison de
l'l'inflation", dit-elle,
nonotamment en raison de mauvais
coconditions météorologiques
cacausant des interruptions de
trtravail de livraison.
" "L'utilisateur moyen
d'd'une banque alimentaire a
enenviviron 9 $ par jour
popour vivre après s avoir payé
soson loyer", explique-t-il.
"S"Si vous ajoutez à ç ça des ps
d'd'emploi, l'inflation qui
grgrimpe, la seule issue est
lele recours aux banques
alalimentaires".
SoSon réseau, Daily Bread, ne
chchômeme pas. Plus de 124 500 y
viviennent chaque mois.
"C"Ce qu'il faut, dit-il,
c'c'est un meilleur accès
auau logement abordable
etet des salaires décents."
CCôté é étudiant, certains grous
mimilitent pour la gratuité
dedes études postsecondaires.
EtEt un meilleur accès s à
lala nourriture, comme des cents
alalimentaires où les étudiants
popourraient faire leurs courses
àà m moindres coûtsts.
I Ici Camille Feireisen,
R Radio-Canada, Toronto